okay it looks like i'm actually going to
be able to get an upload up for tomorrow
i was able to kind of just scrounge
together a crappy little video here and
uh let's go ahead and get through that
so today we're going to talk about
microservices doesn't really make sense
with the general ordering that i've been
trying to keep up but i kind of threw
that one out the window a little bit ago
in order to keep doing daily uploads so
you know whatever screw it okay so what
is a microservices architecture i'm sure
you've probably heard of this term
before but in the event that you haven't
basically in a lot of systems design
interviews you're asked to kind of
design a huge set of functionality you
know maybe if you're talking about
tinder you're designing both the
messaging the matching
the actual creating and deleting and
locking in of accounts and so basically
there's all this super disjoint
functionality that you're supposed to
design together and typically speaking
using something like a microservice
architecture those are going to kind of
be self-contained services so that you
can have teams working on them
individually
but in order to kind of talk about why
you want to be using microservices and
understand the reasoning for that
let's first look at a monolith
architecture and discuss kind of the
shortcomings that it may have
okay so this is kind of the original
approach that um you know most
technology sites used probably 10 20
years ago the reasoning being that they
are simple to implement and sites didn't
really have the scale that they might
have needed in order to require doing
something else so kind of the the logic
behind this is that all code is more or
less contained in the same repository
you basically just have one centralized
backend application and then that way
the same set of nodes in any cluster is
just going to be responsible for only
running that single application
so as you can see here in the diagram to
the right we have you know all these
different types of logic there's this
logic for handling users this logic for
handling business
for business i guess analytics and then
also for data stuff but they're all kind
of packaged together into one back-end
application and they're all touching
this one centralized database
so what are the benefits of a monolith
approach well there actually are a
decent amount and there's a reason that
people are still using them for starters
it's just easier to implement there's no
added complexity in splitting up your
services into a bunch of different kind
of logical groups and additionally all
code goes into the same repository so
there's kind of only one git repo to
have to actually look after
another useful thing is that it's super
easy to test so as opposed to basically
running unit tests
that rely on other external services and
say like well i hope this one works
and kind of mocking that away what you
can actually do is do a full end-to-end
test because all the code is present so
you can go ahead and actually run
everything like normal
then finally it's relatively easy to
deploy and scale since there's only one
repository you only have to deploy one
thing and then as far as scale goes you
basically just go ahead and deploy that
same repository on more nodes obviously
if you're thinking about this for a
little bit this has its downsides too
but i'll discuss that right now
so you can see there's a pretty dense
slide here and that's because there are
a lot of cons of you know using
monoliths so the first one is just in
terms of maintainability and
organization of the code the fact that
you have this huge application code base
makes it really hard to maintain if you
have a bunch of developers working on
something they're going to be writing in
different styles and it's going to be
harder to keep consistent and
additionally any new developer that kind
of tries to jump into this monolith and
start getting working is going to have a
harder time getting adjusted to that
additionally and this is probably the
biggest issue is that deployments are
huge and they take a while if you make a
single code change you're going to have
to redeploy your entire monolith and
that means that you're going to have a
ton of downtime for that service and
that's not just you know
say a two percent chunk of your entire
company that's a hundred percent of your
company for potentially just a small
change
additionally it's pretty hard for
multiple teams to kind of work on um
a monolith at the same time why because
they're all working in different areas
and so you're gonna have a ton of code
to merge in if one team makes a bug and
accidentally merges that in because they
were doing a shitty job testing that can
totally block another team because the
code won't compile and the other team
will have no idea why because you know
they're not the ones writing that code
they have no clue what the other team
did and then finally like i mentioned
you know even small changes are just
going to require a complete redeploy
which are going to be super duper slow
okay next
in terms of actually scaling i mentioned
that monoliths are easy to scale because
you just take that one service or that
one back-end application and put it on
more nodes well that's true but it also
means that for example if you are i
don't know like facebook and you have
all these different services and say
facebook shopping is starting to get
really popular while the newsfeed has
similar load to before you just want to
be able to scale out the the part of
your service that is getting more
popular because otherwise you're just
wasting a ton of compute by scaling out
your entire application linearly so
obviously you want to be able to kind of
do independent scaling on pieces of your
application at once and then finally
this is another huge deal is that
imagine we have this entire site and the
back end is written in java and then you
know someone comes along and says wait a
second kotlin is actually better we like
that language well if it's a monolith
you're going to have to go write that
entire thing
so
that is not going to work if you want to
do some sort of agile development it
would probably be better if you could
kind of split your service into chunks
and only rewrite pieces at a time and
get that done gradually because each
team has different priorities
this is obviously where microservice
architectures come in so if you look at
the diagram on the right we have this
one centralized user interface that you
know the front end user is seeing and
then on the back end we have all of
these different mini kind of back
back-end applications that are capable
of communicating with each other and
then even have their own separate
databases for just the portion of data
that they're responsible for holding
generally speaking these guys just use
rest endpoints or http endpoints to
communicate with one another although
i'm sure
some services use soap i think while i
was at amazon that's what they were
doing there and so as a result of that
kind of each of these microservices
treats one another as if it were its own
independent unit of compute and as a
result each microservice can be you know
developed independently by each team
deployed and scaled independently by
each team and using a tech stack that
each team is most comfortable with so
like i said this honestly goes super far
in terms of fixing the problems that i
mentioned in the previous slide
um just in terms of a quick aside
because i feel like i'm probably not
going to have another chance to mention
this again on the channel at least
anytime soon and i want to be able to
kind of bring it up once in the event
that it comes up in a systems design
interview
because so many companies have now
started moving to these microservice
architectures this is where something
like docker comes in which is super
useful now if you haven't heard of it
docker is actually a devops tool which
means that it's really important for
actually deploying your code and kind of
managing it but not necessarily adding
uh extra functionality to your code
itself
but it's extremely relevant for
microservice architectures so just as an
overview of what docker is docker takes
your code or your back end application
or your background microservice and
packages it into a container
so this is super useful because that
container not only has the code itself
but all of its dependencies libraries
and binaries that it rely on that it
relies on so
by virtue of this it means that
regardless of what environment you're
running that code in whether it's on
your laptop and you're a developer or
it's in the testing environment on the
cloud or the production environment that
you know people around the world are
accessing that code is going to be
running using consistent dependencies
that entire time and as a result you're
not going to have any like platform
specific bugs which is huge
additionally and this is kind of where
docker comes in to be so helpful for
microservices is that it is effectively
a lightweight operating system so here's
how that helps us generally speaking
since most applications are being
deployed to some huge cloud these days
where you have just gigantic server
racks and the server can basically just
be partitioned into virtual machines and
you can figure how much
capacity you want on each virtual
machine it would be really bad if we had
say like i don't know imagine five or
ten different microservices and then for
each of those microservices we had to
configure a virtual machine what if one
of those microservices was either using
too little or more resources than we
thought that we needed for it and then
as a result we're either going to be
under kind of not using enough capacity
in the virtual machine or we're even
going to be wasting money by
having given a certain micro service too
big of a virtual machine so instead what
we can actually do
is you configure this virtual machine
just one you throw a bunch of docker
containers onto it and then the
containers on their own can actually
kind of scale up and scale down on that
virtual machine in order to take just
the resources that they need and as a
result of this if you're a company this
is great because it makes it super easy
to just choose one value in terms of
what you can afford to have in terms of
compute and then the docker containers
will kind of sort themselves out in
terms of hey microservice1 gets a lot of
compute microservice 2 gets less 3 gets
a medium amount
but generally speaking that flexibility
is huge because it means you don't have
to pre-configure all of these virtual
machines and waste a ton of money and
waste a ton of compute
okay so in conclusion
if you're a small company or you're just
starting out with one team generally
speaking that probably makes sense to
use a monolith architecture just because
you're not implementing a ton of
functionality most likely and generally
speaking you don't want to develop for a
bunch of scale that you don't yet have
it just tends to waste time and you may
end up going back on that later so sure
monoliths are fine there but for
companies at huge scale like fan
companies or you know any of them with
you know millions or even billions of
users generally speaking kind of
decoupling all of this functionality
into their own separate microservices is
something that can really speed up the
development process as a whole and make
it so that it's much easier to kind of
have individual teams going and doing
their own thing and then coming back
together by virtue of
wiring these microservices together
okay i hope this one makes sense it's
not too complex of a thing but in some
systems design interviews they'll want
to kind of make sure that you understand
why you're not just having an entire
block of a service that gets deployed
together so um okay have a good one guys
i'm glad i can keep posting